Rüdiger von Fritsch ist bei uns Herr von
Fritsch bis 2019 waren sie Botschafter
in Moskau sie sind etliche Male will er
die mir Putin begegnet wie sehr ist er
unter Druck
er war zu Beginn seiner Amtszeit
eigentlich schwach 2000 er ist einmal
unter großen Druck geraten 2011/12 also
es ist Massenproteste gegen ihn gab aber
er war noch nie so unter Druck wie jetzt
international wie auch
innenpolitisch und damit versucht der
umzugehen und das führt uns zu dem
tragischen Schluss das Vladimir Putin
aus seiner Sicht diesen Krieg nicht
verlieren darf weil er in der Ukraine
inzwischen nicht nur darum kämpft die
Ukraine zu unterjochen Gebiet zu
annektieren den Westen zu drohen er
kämpft um seine eigene Macht zu Hause
inzwischen auch
wir sind Norbert Röttgen aus dem
Politiker der CDU CSU wahrscheinlich
relativ schnell der Meinung dass es ein
Zeichen der Schwäche ist was Putin nun
als Plan vorgelegt hat ist es deshalb
weniger gefährlich
ja ich glaube dass seine Stärke
gefährlicher ist als seine Schwäche ich
glaube das Grundproblem Russlands ist
eine Schwäche und nicht seine Stärke
aber ich bin davon überzeugt dass es für
das für unser Ziel dass wir zu einer
politischen Lösung kommen dass wieder
Diplomatie Konflikte regelt und nicht
Waffen das dafür
die das die militärische und politische
Schwäche ein Schritt ist um das Ziel zu
erreichen und Putins militärische Stärke
wäre das Gegenteil von einem Schritt
hinzufrieden ja die Schwäche ist besser
sie glauben dass das jetzt aber dennoch
eine Eskalation ist die wir erleben ich
habe als das Wort immer wieder kam in
dem einleitungsbericht überlegt ist das
ist das wirklich Eskalation oder ist es
nicht mindestens mehr in die Richtung
Verzweiflungstat das ist zu viel gesagt
würde ich sagen aber wir von Fritsch
sagt er ist wirklich unter Druck zu
Hause massiv wirklich inzwischen schon
massiv auch im Ausland ich würde sagen
es ist der das Stadium erreicht dass
seine Autorität bröckelt und er musste
etwas tun und ich glaube er hat etwas
getan was vor allen Dingen mit der
Teilmobilmachung eigentlich
kontraproduktiv ist erstens wird das
militärisch noch drei vier fünf sechs
Monate dauern bis da überhaupt was kommt
aber er hat jetzt dem eigenen Volk den
jungen Leuten Angst gemacht und und der
hat das auch ausgelöst er hat jetzt
wirkliche Proteste gegen die er nicht
wirklich vorgehen kann also er hat
eigentlich etwas Konter hat in seiner
Not in seinem Druck etwas
scheinbar befreiendes was nach
Eskalation aussieht aber im wirklichen
Effekt eigentlich kontraproduktiv ist
und seine Schwäche weiter verstärken
wird das klingt bei ist bei uns der
SPD-Vorsitzende auch Olaf Scholz sagte
das ist ein Zeichen ein Akt der
Verzweiflung und ein schlimmer falscher
Schritt den Putin der geht sagte Robert
Habeck mit welcher Reaktion aus Moskau
hätte man aber rechnen sollen nachdem
die Ukraine eben auch entscheidende
Gewinne gemacht hat Geländegewinne Putin
würde ja seinen Plan nicht aufgeben aber
erstmal ist das ein großer Erfolg für
die Ukraine und wenn ich mir angucke wie
die Debatten gelaufen sind ich meine
kurz nachdem er angefangen hat mit
diesem völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg haben
wir viele Experten noch gesagt das
dauert eine Woche zehn Tage dann hat er
die ganze Ukraine eingenommen jetzt
sehen wir wie mutig dort gekämpft wird
und in der Tat werte ich das dann auch
als Situation in der Putin unter Druck
ist er versucht jetzt mit unserer Angst
zu spielen deswegen auch diese Drohung
ich finde davon darf man sich nicht
beeindrucken lassen trotzdem müssen wir
natürlich gucken wie beim
verantwortungsvoll mit der Situation
umgeht und ich teile das was ja Röttgen
gesagt hat dieser Krieg kommt jetzt
gerade in den Küchentischen in Russland
an es wird jetzt in den Familien drüber
geredet was diese mobil machen bedeutet
wir haben heute Bilder gesehen von
Familienvätern die unter Tränen ihre
Familien verlassen mussten viele die
damit auch rechnen dass sie nicht
zurückkommen und der Widerstand auch von
mutigen Russinnen und Russen ist gestern
sichtbar geworden und ich glaube das ist
Putin noch mal unter Druck setzen wird
zusätzlich aber natürlich den Satz will
ich noch sagen wir müssen was auch immer
fragen was kann das jetzt bedeuten und
deswegen geht es auch darum sorgsam
abzuwägen was jetzt nichts das tun
Kathrin Eigendorf ist bei uns sie waren
noch bis vor wenigen Tagen Kathrin in
der Ostukraine beide Seiten sagen ja
immer wie groß die Verluste der jeweils
anderen Seite sind welche Zahlen gibt es
die Zahlen halte ich für komplett
unrealistisch von denen wir erfahren
weil weder die Ukraine ist bereit
wirkliche
Opferzahlen bekannt zu geben noch sind
es die Russen also das rangier hat ja
eine eine Rangierung die geht von 30.000
bis 3000 auf russischer Seite wie wollen
wir das nachprüfen in der Ukraine lässt
sich das genauso schwer nachprüfen es
gibt gewisse Indizien also ich spreche
immer mit Militärärzten und habe ein
zwei zu denen ich ein
Vertrauensverhältnis aufgebaut habe und
die mir über den Verlauf des Krieges
einfach immer mal wieder einen Eindruck
gegeben haben und die Verluste auch die
Verletzungen auf auf ukrainischer Seite
sind enorm hoch die Ukraine kämpft mit
enormen Verlusten unter ihren Soldaten
und der Preis den das Land dafür zahlt
diesen Krieg zu führen auch mit Mangel
an westlichen Waffen
müssen Sie einfach mit ihren Soldaten
ausgleichen also der Westen kann eine
Menge liefern aber nicht Menschen
liefern das wäre eine logische nächste
Frage hat die Ukraine noch genug
Reserven um zusätzlich zu dieser Front
im Osten und im Norden tatsächlich auch
noch eine nächste Front im Süden
aufzumachen ja wie wir ja sehen ist ja
weder die Anzahl an Soldaten noch die
technische Überlegenheit Russland
nützlich Russland ist sowohl was die
Anzahl seiner zu mobilisierenden und
einzusetzenden Soldaten auch als was die
technische Ausrüstung angeht ja durchaus
in der Vorderhand gewesen ja aber
letztendlich zählt die Moral zählt die
Cleverness zählt auch die Unterstützung
des Westens der Westen hat ja auch das
ist ja auch ein Teil der Geschichte
ukrainische Soldaten ausgebildet in den
letzten Jahren und auch jetzt noch mal
aktiv und das kommt der Ukraine
natürlich zugute Carlo Masala ist bei
uns militärex der bundeswehruniversität
München Herr massaller diese 300.000
Menschen wo kommen die her was können
die und wie lange müssen sie eigentlich
ausgebildet werden um einsatzfähig zu
sein also wo die genau herkommen das
können wir jetzt noch nicht sagen es
gibt sozusagen quoter für bestimmte
Regionen in Russland wie viel die
sozusagen stellen müssen von diesen
300.000 und sehr viel wird wohl aus dem
Westen kommen da steht jetzt so wie wir
das Wissen einigermaßen fest
zu Herrn Klingbeil das heißt dieser
Krieg wird wirklich zu den ethnischen
Russen getragen und das ist ein
ziemliches Novum weil bisher haben die
ethnischen Minderheiten dort an der
Front gekämpft und wenn die gefallen
sind war das ich sage jetzt mal in dem
ganzen Land klingt zynisch aber es war
so relativ egal jetzt geht sozusagen um
die ethnischen Russen und das könnte
eine ganz andere Dimension sein
normalerweise da die Reserve in Russland
also das was wir klassisch aus Reserve
kennen nicht so besonders gut
ausgebildet ist aber schon drei
Kriterien formuliert er hat formuliert
die müssen wir Dienst geleistet haben
genau die müssen Erfahrungen haben
Spezialisten sein und sie müssen Kampf
Erfahrung haben jetzt versuchen Sie mal
300.000 zu finden die all diese drei
Kriterien erfüllen das kriegen sie nicht
hin so also kriegen sie sozusagen junge
ältere Männer die sie ein zwei drei vier
Wochen ausbilden was absolut nicht
reicht und dann an die Front schmeißen
und jetzt kommt dieser der eine Punkt
die Ausbildung und der zweite Punkt ist
wo kriegen die ja Material her russland
hat jetzt schon Probleme seine Truppen
in der Ukraine mit entsprechenden
Material zu versorgen und wenn ich
Material sage heißt das Kleidung da
bricht jetzt der Winter an die
russischen Truppen haben keine Kälte
kein Kälteschutz wo kriegen jetzt
300.000 sozusagen Reservisten
Kälteschutz her
ich könnte jetzt noch so weitergehen das
ist ein Verzweiflungsakt das ist ein
Verzweiflung sagt er meines Erachtens
eher innenpolitisch motiviert ist weil
seit der großen Offensive der Ukrainer
ja die Hardliner in Moskau sagen wir
müssen jetzt general mobil machen wir
müssen die nennen das ja dann krieg und
dann müssen wir im generalmobil machen
und dann nimmt er den Druck weg aber
letzten Endes wird er folgendes machen
er wird 300.000 schlecht ausgebildettete
Männer an die Front schicken da muss man
ganz einfach sagen er schickt jede Menge
Kanonenfutter an die Fronten dass die
erst für die Frühjahrsoffensive gedacht
sein könnten darüber spekuliert auch der
einen oder andere dass man sich
tatsächlich Zeit nimmt die in Ruhe mehr
oder mehr in der Ruhe auszubilden davon
gehen sie nicht aus die sollen sofort an
die von ja das wissen wir nicht aber er
wird ein Problem bekommen wenn sie sich
dem militärische Situation in der
Ukraine anschauen das läuft momentan für
Russland weiterhin schlecht das läuft
nicht sozusagen in der Dramatik schlecht
wie wir das bei der bei der bei den
beiden gegen offensiven gesehen haben
aber es läuft schlecht also ist im Süden
drohen 25 bis 30 bataillonstaktische
Gruppen aufzugeben weil sie von der
Versorgung abgeschnitten sind wir wissen
nicht wie viele das sind aber es sind
maximal 20.000 ich glaube nicht dass das
20.000 werden aber selbst wenn 10.000
sind ist diese südliche Front dann weg
das bringt Putin in noch viel größere
Bedrängnis also er braucht Personal er
kann es sich nicht leisten die Leute
lange auszubilden aber die werden vor
zwei drei Monaten nicht da reinkommen
und wenn es ausgestattet sein nicht
ausgestattet sein und wenn es überhaupt
ein militärischen Effekt zeigen sollte
wo man großes Fragezeichen dahinter
setzen muss dann wird er sich erst in
fünf sechs oder sieben Monaten zeigen
und kann jetzt überhaupt das Blatt nicht
wenden bei uns ist Sabine Adler vom
Deutschlandfunk vor Adler sie sind
spezialisiert seit Jahren Jahrzehnten
auf Osteuropa und auf Russland im
Besonderen nun hat es gestern Proteste
gegeben
erstaunlich viele Proteste gegeben in
verschiedenen Städten Russlands auch
eher unerwartet
in den Städten würden Sie sagen dass die
schon bemerkenswert sind und ein Zeichen
dafür dass diese russische Bevölkerung
sich zur Wehr setzt oder würden Sie
sagen dafür war es einfach dann doch
noch zu wenig
ich fand es nicht erstaunlich ich fand
das
dieses Wort Mobilmachung Mobilisierung
ausgereicht hat um die Panik auszulösen
das putin hatte vollkommen Recht dass er
sich so lange davor gescheut hat und ob
er das Teilmobilmachung nennt oder
Mobilisierung oder Mobilisierung oder
generalmobilisierung das was die Russen
verstanden haben war general
Mobilmachung und zu dieser Sorge und
Panik hat im Grunde genommen Putin
selbst beigetragen und hat auch schon
gut der Verteidigungsminister
beigetragen denn sie haben in dem UKS in
dem sie die mobil machen
durchdeklinieren ein Punkt vergessen
nämlich den Punkt 7 den Punkt 7 der also
man sprang sozusagen in der Liste der
Punkte des UKS von dem Punkt 6 auf 8 und
der 7er das war der wichtige der
beinhaltete
beinhaltete nämlich die Zahl die Zahl
hatte Putin nicht genannt die war auch
nicht nachzulesen die Zahl war geheime
Verschlusssache extrem umstritten und
schon hat sie dann einfach genannt
300.000 und irgendjemand sagte dann eine
Million die
dann genau die Setter hat das heute
rausgefunden im Bezug auf einen Kreml
Menschen und hat dann versucht
hat und diese diese eine Million um die
ist dann ging die stand da die ist
publik geworden aber schon hat einen
ganz wichtigen Fehler gemacht er hat von
25 Millionen Reservisten im Land
gesprochen und 25 Millionen Reservisten
bei 140 Millionen Menschen heißt da hat
jeder der männliche ist und zwei Beine
hat ist da irgendwie muss los und das
hat die Panik ausgelöst und
gemessen daran fand ich ja es waren 40
Orte fast 40 Orte es waren ein paar
tausend Menschen es sind 1400 Personen
festgenommen worden wir müssen uns jetzt
angucken wie die Prozesse gegen sie
ablaufen wie hart Sie werden das was wir
von den ersten Verurteilungen sehen sind
ganz normale reststrafen also zwischen
fünf und 14 Tagen das ist im Grunde
genommen die normale Reaktion immer noch
aber wir müssen wirklich sehen ob sich
das noch mal hochschaukelt ob es eine
welche Protestwelle gibt oder eben die
Abstimmung mit Füßen die ihr massenhaft
stattfindet wir haben
vielleicht irgendwie jetzt an dem Punkt
mal die Gelegenheit Jens Stoltenberg
zuzuhören für einen einzigen Satz der
den er gesagt haben soll in einer der
vielen schalten die es mit den Ländern
der NATO gegeben hat seit Beginn des
Krieges und zwar im April hier das Zitat
ist nato-generalsekretärs
es wäre schlimm wenn Russland den Krieg
gewinnt aber noch schlimmer wenn
Russland den Krieg verliert
noch mal die Frage auch an Herrn Röttgen
und Herrn Masala es ist gegebenenfalls
eine viel druckvollere gefährlichere
Situation und wir machen einfach weiter
ja aber das muss man entscheiden sieht
man das als teilt man diese Einschätzung
und sie ist ja interessant sie sagen sie
teilen die Einschätzung nicht dass es
gefährlicher wäre für die Welt wenn
Putin den Krieg verloren ja genau das
halte ich für eine Frage und meine
Antwort auf die Frage ist nein ich halte
es nicht für gefährlicher das muss man
sich vielleicht mal wirklich und muss
auch diskutieren und klar machen was man
dann sagt wenn man sagt ich will wir
wollen nicht das Russland verliert dann
heißt das dass Russland irgendwie auch
gewinnt wenn Russland irgendwie gewinnt
dann wird die Welt und nicht nur Europa
die Erfahrung machen Krieg als Mittel
der Politik lohnt sich und ich erreiche
ein sehr fauler Frieden es wird gar kein
Frieden sein denn in dem Augenblick in
dem Putin etwas erreicht wird er
weitermachen weitermachen müssen er will
ja auch weitermachen also ein Gewinnen
von Putin bedeutet eine eine Fortsetzung
von krieg ich so und glaube ich muss man
auch mal ehrlich sagen mein was ist was
ist die eigene Meinung ich glaube habe
mich auch dazu durchgerungen und
entschieden zu sagen dass es richtig ist
die Ukraine muss gewinnen das heißt so
dass das ist der wichtigste Punkt um
wieder zufrieden zu kommen wenn ich ganz
überzeugt davon was aber nicht heißt nur
noch einen diesen Einsatz das natürlich
das natürlich alle Fragen von
Provokationen von Demütigung
Erniedrigung das muss alles vermieden
werden ich meine Meinung ist auch der
Krieg hat sich in dem Augenblick nicht
gelohnt in dem der Status Quo vor dem
Krieg Januar 2022 erreicht worden ist
ich wurde nicht zurückgehen auf 2014
sondern ich würde sagen wenn also die
krimente das ist immer noch ein
völkerrechtswidriger Zustand aber ich
würde sagen die deutsche Position sollte
sein das unterstützen wir nicht das muss
politisch diplomatisch erreicht werden
aber wenn man sagen Status quo ante um
lateinisch zu bleiben Status quoante
bellum der Status Quo vor dem Krieg wenn
der wieder erreicht ist dann ist durch
den Krieg viel zerstört aber für Putin
und Russland nichts gewonnen wird das
glaube ich müssen die historische
Lektion sein es ist interessant wir
hören auch gleich Lars Klingbeil noch
mal dazu ich wollte Rüdiger von Fritsch
unbedingt Fragen nach diesem Zitat da
sagt der Nato-Generalsekretär das ist
zitiert es ist kolportiert aus einer
dieser eigentlich
halböffentlichen schaltgespräche die ist
da gegeben hat dass es schlimm wäre wenn
Putin diesen Krieg gewinnt aber even
worse wenn er ihn verliert was löst das
in ihnen aus wenn Sie diesen Satz hören
zunächst darin und daran dass die
Botschaft reizt uns nicht zu sehr Teil
der russischen Propaganda ist und der
angstfalle in der uns laufen lassen will
reizt uns nicht zu sehr und dieses graue
ständig über nuklear wir müssen sehen
rot jetzt nicht erst mit dunkler nach
der russischen Nuklearstrategie hatte er
bereits jetzt die Möglichkeit jederzeit
noch clever awaffen einzusetzen und es
geht am Ende um Abwägung von
Wahrscheinlichkeiten wird er das machen
oder nicht und wenn auch mehr Sinn
gemacht sie einzusetzen und wenn und
wenn er jetzt seine Taktik insofern
ändert dass er dass er massiv mobil
macht ist meine Vermutung dass er
versucht eine bestimmte Position zu
befestigen und zu halten weil sein
Militär so schlecht ausgestattet ist die
kann er als Infanteristen einsetzen die
können da unten die Linie halten das
wird wieder Ukraine auch sehr schwer
dagegen vorzugehen und das zu erreichen
was er ihr neuerdings quasi als ein
Minimalziel verkündet hat in seiner Rede
nämlich den von den Nazis bedrohten
Russen im Donbass geholfen zu haben und
da kann er mit seiner Propaganda zu
Hause immer noch Sieg erklären wenn das
nach einem Zermürbungskrieg auf ein
Waffenstillstand hinauslaufen sollte auf
den die Ukrainer sich einlassen können
das entscheiden in einem
Waffenstillstand ist allerdings behält
jemand die stärkeren Hebel in der Hand
es darf kein Waffenstillstand sein bei
dem die Russen anschließend Ukraine am
sagen wenn ihr hier nicht auf der
gepunkteten Linie unterschreibt machen
wir weiter das macht die Lösung des
Konfliktes und wir sind ja mit einem
zweiten Faktum konfrontiert Kathrin
Eigendorf nämlich mit diesen
scheinenreferenten das und unter welchen
Bedingungen die stattfinden ist
hinlänglich beschrieben wir können uns
das auf der Karte auch noch mal angucken
das sind insgesamt vier oblasts vier
Bezirke die in denen sie stattfinden
sollen da gibt quasi an den Gürtel
für diese gesamte südostregion wie diese
Referenten in den besetzten Gebiet
ausgehen das Malen wir uns aus wer wohnt
da jetzt überhaupt noch
ja da wohnt schon noch ukrainische
Bevölkerung aber viele Leute sind
natürlich geflohen wir haben in der
Ukraine im Moment einen gravierendes
Problem das Leute natürlich hin und
hergerissen sind die in diesen Regionen
leben das haben wir jetzt in den zuletzt
befreiten Gebieten erlebt die über sechs
Monate ja unter russischer Besatzung
waren wie verhalten Sie sich und es hat
ja da auch kohlebarateure gegeben die
mit den Russen zusammengearbeitet haben
also ich war selber dort und habe eine
Situation erlebt da hat mir eine alte
Dame auf der Straße gesagt wissen sie
meine Nachbarn die haben von den Russen
Essen angenommen die haben mit den
Russen gesprochen mein Sohn hat mir
gesagt du nimmst von den Russen nichts
zu essen an du stirbst er und ich habe
sechs Monate im Keller gelebt und ich
von Kartoffeln und dem was mein Garten
hergegeben hat ernährt und das ist
natürlich eine Situation in der die in
der die Ukraine jetzt auch
innenpolitisch sehr unter Druck gerät
und Konflikte einfach vorprogrammiert ja
und es sind diese
laborationsvorwürfe die sind ja auch
schwerwiegend also und die Ukraine zieht
ja mittlerweile auch ziemlich drastische
Konsequenzen also es ist ja in der
Debatte jetzt ein Gesetz wonach
ukrainische Staatsbürger die einen
russischen Pass beantragen mit bis zu 15
Jahren Haft bestraft werden sollen aber
wir müssen uns nicht vormachen wir haben
es ja erlebt 2014 bei den auch damals
schon scheinreferenten wir haben sie
damals Referenten genannt und auch die
Krim war ein scheinreferendum das unter
Waffengewalt entstanden ist das ist ja
keine wirkliche Abstimmung gewesen
sondern im Prinzip ist die gesamte
Separatistenbewegung der Ukraine ein
russisches Konstrukt es hat nie einen
starken ukrainischen Separatismus
gegeben der eine Abspannung
und alle die wir erleben also ein Dennis
pusheen zum Beispiel der ja jetzt den
Kreml zu Anfang des Krieges dazu
aufgerufen hat
praktisch einzuschreiten sie zu retten
das ist ja die Strategie Russlands und
deswegen
legt Putin ja auch so viel Wert darauf
und ist das ein wichtiger Faktor in
diesem Krieg diese referentenschein
Referenten durchzuführen ja klar und die
danach müssen wir jetzt auch noch mal
fragen weil sie haben automatisch
Konsequenzen für den Westen Herr klingen
weil das muss man verstehen wenn Putin
übermorgen diese Gebiete zur russischen
Territorium erklären dann sind auch alle
Angriffe auf dieses vermeintlich
russische Territorium
Angriffe gegen Russland und gegen Moskau
und er könnte das was er jetzt selber
noch spezialoperationen nennt im Grunde
zu einem de facto Krieg zwischen
Russland der Ukraine und der NATO
erklären ist das in ihren Augen egal
also ich glaube das ist das was ich in
Putins Kopf abspielt als Szenario aber
deswegen war es gestern wichtig dass der
deutsche Bundeskanzler das Joe Biden
dass alle gestern sehr klar gesagt haben
wir werden diese Referenten nicht
anerkennen das ist auch der Unterschied
zu 2014 wenn man das auch nichts
anerkannt worden aber damals war der
Westen viel zu leise als das in der Krim
passiert ist und wir haben jetzt eine
komplett andere Situation gestern waren
alle sofort auf dem Platz haben deutlich
gemacht das werden wir nicht akzeptieren
und ich will ja auch sagen es ist ja
noch etwas weiteres passiert in der
letzten Woche dass wir auch sehen dass
beispielsweise China sich wegbewegt von
Russland die standen sehr lange sehr
fest so war zumindest der Eindruck an
der Seite Russland ist ja nicht nur im
Westen isoliert es fängt nicht nur an
einem Land zu bröckeln sondern wir
erleben auch das frühere Bündnispartner
oder vermeintliche Bündnispartner sich
von Russland distanzieren aber was die
Referenten angeht will ich ganz klar
sagen dass die Grundlage ob es
irgendeine Form auch der der Anerkennung
oder des Schweigens im Westen gibt und
das war gestern sehr klar dass wir nicht
passieren hat aber sehr klar formuliert
dass er und unter anderem auch Joe Biden
und alle NATO-Länder dass sie keine
Waffen zur Verfügung stellen wollen die
oder mit denen man russisches
Territorium angreifen könnte wenn nun
Putin aber russ das ist Territorium zur
russischen Territorium erklärt wie
verhält sich dann der Westen aber das
ist das was ich vorhin gesagt habe er
versucht uns Angst zu machen er versucht
uns genau in diese abwägungsfragen
reinzubringen und ich finde an der
Stelle müssen wir sehr konsequent sein
die Ukraine hat das Recht sich zu
verteidigen wir tun seit Tag eins als
Westen geschlossen alles um juckreien zu
stärken viele der militärischen Erfolge
die gerade passieren passieren ja
aufgrund dessen so jetzt weiß ich dass
der Röntgen immer noch Vorstellung hat
was man noch mehr machen kann das sieht
die Ampel ein bisschen anders aber
trotzdem kann man ja als Fakt erst mal
sagen wir tun sehr viel um die Ukraine
in dieser Position zu stärken und das
wird weitergehen also wir lassen uns
nicht davon beeindrucken dass es diese
Referenten gibt wir lassen uns nicht von
dem Bedrohung von den Putin beeindrucken
und das ist kein russisches Territorium
das wird auch kein russisches
Territorium werden da sind wir sehr klar
da sind sie sehr klar und wir sind bei
Carlo Masala und sagen diese Schlacht
die da im Nordosten gewonnen wurde durch
die Ukraine diese gebietgewinne die sind
ja
recht mächtig
diese eine also was war das 3000 Hektar
kann diese Region kann diese eine
Befreiung tatsächlich den Unterschied
schon machen würden Sie sagen das ist
jetzt eine Wende im Krieg ob es eine
Wende im Krieg ist das wenn wir sehen
weil es von den Faktoren abhängt die
sich jetzt erst in den nächsten Wochen
entscheiden werden es ist zum Beispiel
schaffen es die Russen sich auf ein sich
auf eine Verteidigungslinie
zurückzuziehen von wo sie Sachen halten
können das versuchen Sie sie versuchen
sozusagen den aus Kiel also diesen Fluss
als Verteidigungslinie zu halten die
Ukrainer sind sehr erfolgreich Ihnen das
noch zu verwehren die Frage ist wie
lange
was die Ukraine momentan machen und zwar
sowohl im Süden als auch im Osten oder
im Nordosten sie halten die Russen in
Bewegung
sie zerstören weiter Logistik also Herr
Sonne wird weiterhin Logistik zerstört
das ist für den Süden wichtig und es
geht vor allen Dingen darum die Russen
in Bewegung zu halten zu verhindern dass
die Russen sich auf befestigte
Verteidigungslinien seien sie natürlich
oder seien sie sozusagen geschaffen
zurückziehen können weil dann fallen wir
wieder in diesen Krieg zurück den wir
von ich weiß jetzt nicht Mai bis August
hatten also sozusagen eine
Stellungskrieg wo sich eine Seite
vielleicht um 0,3 km am Tag bewegt und
am nächsten Tag davon wieder 0,1 km
verliert und das ist das was die
Ukrainer gerade machen und zwar durchaus
erfolgreich also jetzt kurz bevor diese
Sendung angefangen hat gibt es noch
unbestätigt aber es merkt sich Gerüchte
dass im Nordosten von Liman einen
Durchbruch gelungen ist bachmut
sozusagen scheint sehr erfolgreich zu
sein Herr son ist im Norden und im im
Osten sozusagen von den Ukrainern
angegriffen worden logistische Anlagen
sind zerstört worden also die Taktik der
Ukraine hat das dient ja alles der
Vorbereitung einer neuen Offensive ja da
geht es wieder wie bei der alten
Logistik zerstören Schwächen in der
russischen Verteidigungslinie finden und
was wir natürlich die nächsten Tage
gefallen werden sind verstärkte Angriffe
auf die Oblaste und die zentralen
Stellen wo das
scheintreferendum durchgeführt werden
sollte
Explosionen heute richtig unter ist
natürlich auch die Frage da müssen die
Ukrainer ja auch eigene also Ukrainer
beschießen ist das noch zusätzlich
Katrin Eickendorf einen
Konfliktpotenzial
das ist in diesem Krieg immer ein
Konfliktpotenzial gewesen das war auch
2014 schon ein Konfliktpotenzial
natürlich das ist ein Krieg der wird auf
ukrainischem Boden auf ausgetragen
ausgetragen und da werden auch Ukrainer
auf Ukrainer schießen und die werden
dann eben für diesen Krieg Zahlen
ich denke nur mittlerweile hat sich die
Wahrnehmung in der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung doch deutlich verschoben
also 2014 konnte man ja noch erleben das
Putins narrativ das in Kiew eine
faschistische Regierung die Macht
ergriffen hat und er den Osten davon
beschützen oder befreien muss die hat ja
gezogen es haben ja Menschen in der
Ukraine tatsächlich geglaubt dass die
ukrainische Armee ihre Kinder tötet
das ist wirklich eine katastrophale
Vorstellung also da hat es narrative
gegeben die sind wirklich ganz
erschreckend die die Menschen geglaubt
haben das ist jetzt nicht mehr so wenn
man heute mit den Menschen spricht in
den besetzten Gebieten die jetzt befreit
wurden die sagen alle ganz klar gerade
eine Stadt wie es um Bad total im
Prinzip eine Sowjet statt ja die ganz
klar an russischer Seite stand heute ist
das nicht mehr so also die sehen
Russland ganz klar als Feind und sagen
das war damals ein Irrtum das zu glauben
Putin wollte nie unsere Interessen
vertreten
interessanterweise ist gerade heute mit
diesen bekannt gewordenen
Gefangenenaustausch ein Mann
freigelassen worden frei gekauft worden
von den Russen im Gegenzug hat die
Ukraine 200 Soldaten ehemals
assoff-kämpfer bekommen das ist Viktor
Mitwirkung und das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Mann weil sie gerade sagten
fragen darf dieses narrativ von den
Faschisten in Kiew das war dieser Mann
zu dieser Mann hat
2004 2005 bei der orangen Revolution die
gegen kutschmar stattgefunden hat zu
dieser Zeit hat dieser Mann von den
Faschisten auf dem Maidan gesprochen den
Demonstranten sie alle kollektive
abqualifiziert als Faschisten und damit
auch dieses neue demokratische die neuen
demokratischen Kräfte um juschenko und
Timoschenko diskreditiert das ganze
haben wir 2013 auf dem euromider noch
mal erlebt 2014 wieder diese gesamte
Diskreditierung als Faschisten und das
dann kulminiert bis zu diesen
Kriegsgrund man müsste die Ukraine vom
Faschismus befreien also das ist mit
Bezug da so hat sich so langfristig hat
sich das auch aufgebaut das finde ich
wirklich eine wichtige Information und
dieser Mann ist ein enger Freund von
Protein
zu dem Vorwurf des Faschismus weil er
immer wieder auftaucht und Putins jede
dritte Wort hatte man das Gefühl in
seiner Rede war ja die Nazis in Kiew
warum spielt das eine solche Rolle
diesen groben Unfug zu behaupten weil es
einer der letzten Punkte ist auf die
sich Vladimir Putin mit seinem Volk
verständigen kann das ist das was das
Volk einmal geeint hat der Kampf gegen
die Faschisten 1945 und er muss
behaupten da stehen wir wieder und das
zeigt auch in welch schwieriger
Situation er ist überhaupt die Menschen
auf seiner Seite zu haben weil er ihn
sonst nichts anzubieten hat dieses Land
dieses Regime hat keine attraktive
Zukunftsperspektive im eigenen Land
geschweige denn sonst wo nicht der
Sowjet Kommunismus konnte man eine
Angola noch begeistert Feiern von mir
aus aber Russland hat nichts anzubieten
und deswegen diese Rolle rückwärts in
die Vergangenheit der Versuch das Volk
der zusammenzuführen und die Frage die
Putin sich stellen muss ist kann und
wird das auf Dauer halten wird dieses
Bündnis zwischen ihm und dem Volk halten
im Moment würde ich sagen stehen die
Menschen überwiegend noch auf seiner
Seite aber es muss nicht auf Dauer gut
gehen so und wir verstehen und erinnern
uns ja nochmal daran wie weit eigentlich
sein historischer Rückgriff ist um die
Ukraine nicht als Ukrainer zu bezeichnen
sondern als kleinen Russen und um
Zusagen dieser Staat hat eigentlich das
Recht verwirkt überhaupt zu existieren
und zwar historisch und jetzt macht er
ja ein weiteres nicht nur dass diese
scheinreferenten stattfinden er droht ja
neuerlich mit einem atomaren Schlag
wahrscheinlich mit taktischen Waffen
weil sonst wäre ja sofort berechenbar
welche Reaktion ist da aus Amerika gäbe
wie besonders gefährlich oder wie
wahrscheinlich wie viel wahrscheinlicher
ist das jetzt noch mal in ihren Augen
haben wir's ich glaube die Gefahr eines
Einsatzes von Nuklearwaffen hat sich
nicht erhöht durch diese Rede ja aus
also ich meine es ist schon auffällig
dass sozusagen der der Präsident des
Staates der numerisch die meisten n
haarwaffen hat sich gezwungen sieht
nachdem er sieben Monate lang nukleare
Drohungen ausstößt jetzt noch zu sagen
das ist kein Bluff ja also das zeigt
sozusagen wie auch dort realisiert wurde
dass diese ganze abschreckungslogik der
letzten sieben Monate wir drohen euch
mit nuklearschlägen also liefert keine
Waffen macht nicht unterstützt die
Ukraine nicht dass das verpufft ist der
Westen hat sich ja sehr klug verhalten
er ist ja überhaupt nicht darauf
eingegangen also muss dieser Mann jetzt
sagen dass das kein Bluff ist das ist
letzten Endes sehr zugespitzt gesagt
eine Bankrott Erklärung so aber an dem
mit dem Rücken an der Wand steht wie
jetzt geschrieben zweiter Punkt
der Preis für den Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen ist für Putin extrem hoch
also erstens gibt es sozusagen die Frage
Joe Biden vor drei Tagen indem er
dreimal gesagt hat mach es nicht mach es
nicht mach es nicht
Stoltenberg der gestern noch mal gesagt
hat das wird eine Reaktion der NATO
hervorrufen wir wissen nicht welche so
das hat Putin eingepreist und aber was
wir sehen jetzt genau was wir sehen
jetzt ist folgendes die Chinesen haben
sich extrem auf der
Überprüfungskonferenz das nicht
verbreitungsvertrages extrem besorgt
über die Situation ist aporedischer
gezeigt weil sie keinerlei Lust haben
dass dort ein Reaktor in die Luft fliegt
und wir ein zweites Tschernobyl haben
oder noch ein größeres Tschernobyl die
Reden des indischen und des chinesischen
Außenministers Außenministers ja bei der
UN-Generalversammlung waren sehr
eindeutig mit Blick auf sozusagen
nuklearfragen China und Indien
auslandsverhalten insgesamt genau China
und Indien meine Vermutung würden ihm da
nicht beistehen und das würde bedeuten
dass Putin das schafft was wir als
Westen nicht geschafft haben nämlich die
komplette internationale Isolation
selbst erklärt
noch nicht ganz kurz was ich will das
jetzt nicht verharmlosen ja also der
Mann hat diese Waffen und deswegen muss
man potenziell immer in einen Einsatz
denken es gibt nicht wenige die
Wahrscheinlichkeit größer und die
häufiger er verliert umso größer wird
die Gefahr die Frage aber er ist kein so
als suizidaler Akteur das heißt der
Einsatz von nuklear war von muss ja
irgendeinen strategisches Ziel verfolgen
und die Frage ist was für ein
strategisches Ziel Abschreckung
unsererseits was will er denn machen 30
40 Nuklearwaffen auf Kiew abfeuern das
halte ich für völlig übertrieben ja also
sozusagen wo ist der abschreckende
Effekt er wird international isoliert
was hat er zu gewinnen natürlich es kann
immer eine Situation eintreten indem er
sozusagen sich so an der Wand gedrückt
fühlt aber diese Situation hätte auch in
den letzten Monaten eintreten können
Herr von Fritsch zum Thema Rücken zur
Wand
Wladimir Putin ist nicht verrückt er ist
nicht irrational er handelt nach einer
anderen Rationalität und in der ist er
sehr rational und dazu gehört die Herr
Masala richtig sagt das zur
Gesamtkonzeption russischer
Militärstrategie an bestimmten Punkten
der einsatznuklearer Waffen gehören kann
nur wird er das mehrfacher Abwägung
unterziehen und ich habe sehr stark den
Eindruck dass sowohl die chinesische wie
die indische Führung im sehr klar
signalisiert hat dass sie diesen
ultimativen tabu-bruch der
internationalen Politik der ist ja wäre
nicht wünscht und das an diesem Punkt
auch zu Hause er fürchten müsste erstens
das Volk endgültig gegen sich zu haben
weil er sie zum nuklearparier macht und
weil es an dem Punkt welche geben könnte
die ihm dann doch in den Arm fallen
genau so dann sind wir bei der nächsten
Frage es kann eben es ist schon
angeklungen bei Carlo Masala vor
Eugendorf es kann eine einen atomaren
Anschlag geben es kann aber auch eine
atomare Katastrophe geben das ist
bewusst oder unbewusst eben
beispielsweise Atomkraftwerke andere
Einrichtungen trifft wie in
saporicia ja irgendwie zu befürchten
stand
da haben saporicia haben die Russen
jetzt besetzt mit welcher Begründung
sollten Sie das beschießen also auch da
sagt der Westen ja die putinen Männer
drohen mit zünden mit diesem Holz warum
sollten die Russen sich selbst in Gefahr
bringen
also sie gehen dieses Risiko in dem Fall
sehr bewusst ein denn ein Kernkraftwerk
und saporis ist das größte Kernkraftwerk
Europas in eine solche Situation zu
bringen inmitten in einer Kampfzone zu
sein und das haben die Russen getan und
nicht die Ukraine ist ein großes Risiko
alleine die Tatsache die Angestellten
die dort für die Sicherheit zuständig
sind unter eine permanente
Stresssituation zu bringen wirkten
Risiko das ist das ist ein Spiel mit dem
Feuer aber ich würde gerne noch mal den
Blick drauf lenken wenn wir uns heute
mit der Frage beschäftigen was wird
Wladimir Putin tun und was ist die
richtige Reaktion des Westens glaube ich
müssen wir den Blick mal auf die
Gesamtlänge des Konfliktes legen der es
ist ja ein Konflikt nicht zwischen der
Ukraine und Russland allein sondern
wladimir Putin hat den Westen den Krieg
angesagt und der Westen hat über viele
viele Jahre immer versucht den Weg der
Diplomatie zu gehen immer den Weg der
Zugeständnisse hat sich Putin
merkwürdige innovative zu eigen gemacht
mit die NATO ist ihm zu sehr nahe
gerückt das hat nicht funktioniert und
jetzt haben wir eine Situation ab dem 24
Februar
da hat der Westen auf einmal schlagartig
seine Position geändert und harte Kante
gezeigt
und auf einmal steht Putin mit dem
Rücken zur Wand er hat einen Fehler nach
dem anderen gemacht es hat nicht nicht
eines seiner Ziele ist eingetreten und
da muss man sich doch mal überlegen was
ist eigentlich die richtige Politik
Politik im Umgang mit diesem Regime wir
sind damit im Grunde hätte ich es nicht
schöner sagen können sofort auch in
Deutschland weil um diese Politik
gegenüber Wladimir Putin ist in
Deutschland ja schwer gekämpft worden
Frau Adler hat darüber einen Buch
geschrieben und ich sag's mal salopp
ordentlich ausgeteilt sowohl in Bezug
auf die Sozialdemokratie als auch in
Bezug auf die Politik gegenüber der
Ukraine
seitens der Christdemokraten und der
CSU würden Sie sagen da hat irgendjemand
den größeren und den wichtigeren Fehler
gemacht in unserem politischen agieren
mit Wladimir Putin also die politische
Klasse hat insgesamt Fehler gemacht weil
niemand diese Energiepolitik die
fünf in die falsche Richtung marschierte
ist und zwar komplett und mit voller
Kraft und nur immer in diese eine
Richtung marschiert ist irgendwie
gestoppt hat es gab es gab einfach
keinen Korrektiv es gab dieses Korrektiv
nicht von der SPD sowieso nicht weil sie
die Initiatoren wahr zunächst mit
Gerhard Schröder und Angela Merkel als
Kanzlerin 2005 hätte die Möglichkeit
gehabt zu sagen mit diesem Mann Putin
den Merkel gut einschätzen konnte 2005
der 2005 schon einen Tschetschenienkrieg
brutal wie Mario Pohl wie harkev und und
auch in Syrien geführt hat sie hätte
erkennen können und das hat sie auch
erkannt aber hat ihn nicht gestoppt mit
diesem Mann kann man ein solches großes
Projekt nicht machen das geht nicht das
darf man nicht das verbietet sich von
selbst das hat sie nicht gemacht im
Gegenteil sie ist auch weiter in die
falsche Richtung mit der SPD an der
Seite marschiert und nach der an und der
Krim und nach dem Krieg in der
osteokraine
ist sie nicht für noch schärfere
Sanktionen eingetreten für Sanktionen
irgendwie schon und auch gemeinsam
verabschiedet schon die gab es aber sie
ist nicht dafür eingetreten erstens auf
gar keinen Fall ein zweites
nordstream-projekt in den Weg in den
Wege zu leiten oder auch mal zu
überlegen ist diese gasabhängigkeit
bisher schon hat die nicht auch zu
Rüstung beigetragen für für Russland zu
dieser Hochrüstung die man auch schon zu
dieser Zeit absehen konnte das heißt
also Merkel ist weitergegangen in diese
Richtung hat mit ihrem
Wirtschaftsminister nordstream 2
angefangen und zwar mitten in dem
Ost-Ukraine Krieg 2015 ist Nord Stream 2
ein halbes Jahr nach dem Minsker
Abkommen sie verhandelt im Minsk 17
Stunden lang um irgendwie einen
Friedensschluss hinzubekommen und
verabschiedet oder schickt ihren
Wirtschaftsminister bisher später nach
Moskau um Nord Stream 2 zu verhandeln
was kann Sigmar Gabriel was kann Putin
daraus schlussfolgern dass er so
weitermachen kann dass er annektieren
kann dass er Krieg führen kann der
Westen die Europäische Union wird ihn
nicht stoppen und das ist das Verhängnis
das ist das Verhängnis was wir jetzt
sehen wir haben Länder Bundesländer die
sind so derartig wirtschaftlich von
Russland abhängig gewesen bis vor kurzem
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern zum Beispiel das
ist quasi ein Ausverkauf ist oder wenn
wir jetzt sprechen über das
petrochemische Werk in Schwedt in
schwedt-pizza Schwedt das ist vor einem
Jahr im November noch nicht mal vor
einem Jahr an rossnerv verkauft worden
vor einem Jahr das heißt also es ging
immer ungebremst in die falsche Richtung
das wichtige Infrastruktur an Russland
abgegeben wurde die Gasspeicher das PCK
Nord Stream 2 und niemand hat diese
Politik wirklich gestoppt und das war
der ein wirklich so großer Fehler dass
ich mich eigentlich Frage und das frage
ich natürlich auch in dem Buch
ist das nicht wert eine Untersuchungs
einen Untersuchungsausschuss im
Bundestag einzusetzen und sich an den
Tisch zu setzen mit dem Ziel
herauszufinden
wer war da an welcher Weise
so sehr von Lobbyisten umzingelt oder ja
ich würde das Wort sogar schon
aussprechen hat da Korruption auch eine
Rolle gespielt
das muss man dringend aufarbeiten denn
diese Zeche dieser jahrelangen falschen
Energiepolitik zahlt jetzt jeder
einzelne Bundesbürger und es werden
Leute in tieferarmut stürzen wenn diese
Energiepreise so sich so andeuten wie
sie sich andeuten und es wird generell
wird ist eine Verarmung der Bevölkerung
geben das ist kein Kassandra Hof das ist
einfach Realität und die einen können
das ehrverkraften als die anderen aber
zu verdanken haben wir das maßgeblich
der SPD und der cdu/csu deshalb ist das
jetzt die große Chance für Norbert
Röttgen und anschließend Lars kriegen
bald zu sagen was tun Sie was macht die
CDU was macht Norbert Röttgen um zu
verhindern dass sowas hier wieder
geschieht
also sie wählen mich jetzt nicht in der
Position finde ich könnte ein paar
Nuancen würde ich etwas anders sehen
aber dass ich jetzt im Jahr 2022 das
verteidige was ich seit 2015 kritisiert
habe ich habe es nicht gestoppt ich
hatte nicht die Machtposition ist zu
stoppen aber ich habe es seit 2015
ununterbrochen und öffentlich mal einmal
aussprechen sie waren die große Ausnahme
der immer wieder gesagt hat das ist
verkehrt diese Art von Energiepolitik
ist verkehrt lasst sie uns nicht machen
das muss man mal einmal gesagt haben so
ja und dann ist trotzdem die Frage
so das wäre jetzt wirklich ein bisschen
absurd aber ich nehme einen Punkt auf ja
dann müssen wir jetzt beide mal wirklich
vielleicht doch hier die Gelegenheit
nehmen ich teile auch diese Einschätzung
dass dass wir Grund haben
aufzuklären wie konnte es gegen die
Offensichtlichkeit der Entwicklung in
ihren Gefahren wie konnte es dazu kommen
was was ist da so grundlegend schief
gelaufen das sagen alle Alarmsignale das
ist immer weiter Zunahmen dass dann
reden der größte Gasspeicher ist wurde
ja nicht nur nordstream 2 noch gemacht
ein Jahr nach nach der Krim Annektion
sondern dann hat die BASF Tochter
Winters Hall hat noch den größten
Gasspeicher verkauft man muss auch mal
über Manuela Schwesig reden sozusagen
wie eine Ministerpräsidentin die heute
noch im Amt ist sozusagen kollusiv gegen
die und also ich wollte die Sendung
letzte Woche und hat gesagt es gab
tatsächlich eine Bundesregierung die
dieses Vorhaben natürlich unterstützt
hat und eine Ministerpräsidentin eines
Landes das hat sie nicht nur gesagt muss
ich dafür hatte aber sagen ich will aber
nur den Schuss von ich finde dass das
verlangt nach Aufklärung weil weil die
die staatlichen Organen in ihrer
Mehrheit und auch wir wirklich in die
falsche Richtung eigentlich also nicht
sehen wir laufen sind und ich schließe
mich dem an und überlegen ich möchte
Rüdiger von gleich ich möchte einmal
Rüdiger von Fritsch Fragen als Diplomat
hatten sie ja wenn sie wenn ich das
einmal kurz erwähnen darf eine Reihe von
diesen Delegationen hoch politischen
Delegationen auch dann betreut schließen
sie sich diese Kritik an sagen sie das
war wirklich von den beiden
Volksparteien eine ganz fatale
Entscheidung was grundsätzlich was
grundsätzlich richtig war war zu einer
Zeit wo sich beide Seiten an die
gleichen Regeln gehalten haben eine
Politik zu führen und mit beiden Seiten
meine ich Russland wieder Westen und
alle eine Politik zu führen die auf der
einen Seite versucht hat in dem Maße wie
das im europäischen Kompromiss möglich
ist mit Entschlossenheit auf die
Verletzung gemeinsam vereinbarte Regeln
reagieren aber auf der anderen Seite
versuchen im Dialog
Konflikte zu lösen und seien Sie so
kompliziert wie das mixabkommen und so
weiter aber reine Konfrontation ich
möchte eines hinzufügen weil wir bei
manchem was man rückblickend betrachten
kann eines doch nicht aus dem Blick
verlieren dürfen es war und es bleibt
grundsätzlich richtig zur versuchen
gemeinsam mit Russland Zukunft auf
dieser arosischen Landmasse zu gestalten
und ganz einfach weil Russland nicht
weggehen wird es bleibt da und Wladimir
Putin nimmt ja auch sein Volk in
Geiselhaft und macht sie mit schuldig
auch wenn sie sich nicht auflehnen oder
so wenn Sie mit dem Geiselhaft und wir
müssen auch denke ich weil wir die ganze
Zeit über den Krieg reden was ja auch
richtig ist darüber hinausblicken wir
müssen jetzt beginnen der Bahn
nachzudenken
und ich möchte trotzdem noch mal sagen
es geht ja nicht darum im Dialog zu
bleiben das komische an diesem Dialog
mit Herrn Putin und seinen Kollegen war
ja dass wir uns erstens in einer
Abhängigkeit brachten und zweitens ja
offensichtlich auch Energie Gas von ihm
bekamen das so wahnsinnig billig war
also wir hatten ja zum einen dieses
tolle Gefühl im Dialog zu sein und auf
der anderen Seite hat Deutschland ja
über Jahre salopp gesagt ein ziemlichen
schnapp gemacht das ist den Genossen
nicht aufgefallen so jetzt ein paar
Gedanken dazu von mir weil ich finde ja
auch in der Tat da haben sie recht Vater
das ist doch meine Aufgabe mit der
SPD-Vorsitzender genau zu gucken was ist
da wie passiert und welche Konsequenzen
sicher für die Zukunft holen erstmal
glaube ich war schon ein breiter
gesellschaftlicher Konsens der weit über
cdu/csu und SPD hinausgehen zu sagen wir
nehmen gern das billige russische Gas
das war auch Teil unseres Erfolgs den
ökonomischen Orten erstmal ist das ein
Fakt so das waren Fehler aber das ist ja
etwas wo es einen großen
gesellschaftlichen Konsens gab den habe
ich alle mitgetragen aber viele in
diesem Land das zweite ist das will ich
auch für meine Partei sagen es gibt ein
Denken das fängt an bei Willy Brandt
Entspannungspolitik dass man mit
Russland kooperieren will und ich habe
in einer Rede die ich vor ein paar
Wochen vor der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung
gehalten habe wo ich auch über die
Neuausrichtung deutsche
außensicherheitspolitik geredet habe
sehr klar für mich festgehalten dass wir
Fehler gemacht haben als Politik aber
auch als SPD weil wir 2008 Georgien 2014
Grimmen nicht richtig gedeutet haben in
der Masse was dort passiert ist einzeln
in SPD ja aber in der Masse nicht und
auch nicht in der deutschen Politik die
Regierungsverantwortung hatte das war
ein Fehler ich sehe diesen Fehler
übrigens am größten auch wenn ich auf
unsere osteuropäischen Bündnispartner
gucke ich war in Polen ich war am
Baltikum da gibt es ein tiefes
Unverständnis für das was passiert ist
und jetzt ist aber wo ich außer ich bin
seit Dezember SPD-Vorsitzender wo es für
mich um die Frage geht was folgt da
draußen also und ich sag mal das Nord
zum Zeug gestoppt ist das Weizen
Selbstverständlichkeit einer Stelle war
notwendig aber dass wir jetzt gucken wie
kann man eine neue Ostpolitik ausrichten
in der ich Polen das Baltikum viel
stärker einbeziehe das ist für mich eine
Konsequenz die daraus folgt also das
sind ja alle Schritte die die erfolgen
gerade 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen für
die Bundeswehr die Bündnis und
Landesverteidigung zu stärken das sind
alles Dinge die Folgen gerade da draußen
aber das geht aber dass die Fehler da
waren das ist klar aber der Bruch und
ich meine das ist offensichtlich gucken
sich die Rede von Olaf Scholz an die er
gerade vor den Vereinten Nationen
gehalten hat das ist dann Deutlichkeit
nicht zu übertreffen der Bruch ist da
Untersuchungsausschüsse
Untersuchungsausschüsse werden von der
Opposition eingesetzt da muss ja Röttgen
was zu sagen aber dass diese
gesellschaftliche Debatte noch mal ich
führe die das kann man auch
nachverfolgen als SPD-Vorsitzender ich
führe die in der Partei ich führe die
öffentlichen Verkehr
Ihnen diese Suppe eingebrockt hat die
Leute wollen wissen warum diese
Gaspreise jetzt so durch die Decke gehen
sie haben eine Menge gesagt aber sie
haben genau das nicht gesagt es muss
einfach raus und Reiter genannt werden
das ist in dieser extrem schwierigen
Situation für dieses Land einfach
wichtig und da kann man da gibt es gibt
einen Aspekt dass das auch in einem
unglaublichen Egoismus geschehen ist in
einem deutschen Egoismus der die
Interessen unserer Nachbarn sträflich
einfach missachtet hat Polen Baltikum
Belarus ja erwähnt erwähnt dass sie dass
sie mit ihm gesprochen haben aber dieser
Egoismus der auch der ist
erklärungsbedürftig für mich geht es
doch als jemand der seit dezember 2021
SPD-Vorsitzenden
Konsequenzen daraus zu ziehen und
deswegen geht es für mich aufzuarbeiten
dass in der Vergangenheit schief
gelaufen ist dass sie tun wird ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob das jetzt die Zuschauer
interessiert aber dass wir in der Partei
diese Debatten führen am 19 Oktober gibt
eine Veranstaltung dazu das werden wir
tun ich bin Partei deswegen tue ich das
gerade und für mich ist zum Beispiel die
Frage Umgang mit China welche
Konsequenzen ziehe ich raus dass
einseitige Abhängigkeiten entstanden
sind und das musst du die Zukunft
verhindert werden ich will nur drei ganz
kurze Punkte machen der eine ist noch
mal zu der Frage Russland ist da und
Russland geht nicht weg das ist richtig
aber ich glaube man muss ganz einfach
realisieren die nächste Dekade
werden wir damit beschäftigt sein
Sicherheit gegen und vor Russland zu
organisieren und sämtliche
Kooperationsangebote an eine Post
putin-regierung die werden mit so einer
sozusagen Vorsicht zu longieren sein und
mit solchen Vorbedingungen sozusagen an
Russland zu adressieren sein dass er
erstmal lange Zeit nicht zu erwarten ist
also ich glaube was wir machen müssen in
der nächsten Dekade ist sich auf uns
konzentrieren Europa plus die USA und
Sicherheit gegen und vor Russland bauen
und danach kann man sozusagen über
kooperative Beziehungen anfangen wieder
nachzudenken der zweite Punkt ist Frau
Adler ich glaube was die Menschen hier
in Deutschland die können alle gern in
Untersuchungsausschuss machen und alle
sozusagen in ihren Parteien und gucken
wie das passiert ist aber ich glaube was
die Menschen hier in Deutschland
beständig verstehen müssen und das geht
mir ein bisschen sozusagen Weg bei
vielen Diskussionsrunden die wir jetzt
haben über Gas und gasumlage und sowas
wir sind in dieser Situation weil es
einen Angriffskrieg gibt
da können wir jetzt natürlich sozusagen
und selber in in Sack und Asche gehen
die Politik damals die war falsch weil
sie keinen Plan B hatte das ist so mein
Punkt